I think it would be cool to just go around town and actually get a lay of the land here in like, downtown LA
See what it's really like out there
I don't really care about it
are you taking any precautions
No
absolutely not
My immune system is good enough, I don't care
When we went out to Texas, the day we landed we found out there was someone confirmed with the coronavirus
They went to a mall in San Antonio where we were filming
For Niko, Jake, Clint, and myself, I brought four N95 masks
Jake really roasted me and made fun of me and made me feel bad, and I almost took it off,
and then we fly back...
New alarm bells ringing tonight on the coronavirus outbreak in this country,
...officials there cautioning people about how they should interact with others going forward
I was right
Now, all this gear is from San Antonio
You know, hey
Hey, this feels good I can finally fistbump you
The best fistbump: obviously like, you know everyone's practicing the elbow thing
Cause you wanna avoid the hands and the wrists
you know, cause the germs can travel down your wrists a little bit
You know what's better? The crossguard
Yea
No, cause look at this, our faces are right in front of each other. If you were to sneeze, I'm... I'm dead
What about your knees? High knees
Knees work! Knees work!
Oh, the knee the knee... Wha-chaa!
Feet?
Pound it
High five
How are you Matt?
Maintains a good six feet from each other
That is something that they say, right? That you have to maintain a distance of like six feet?
You guys are not six feet away from each other
Six feet bro!
Good to see ya
Good to see you Clint
I go to the grocery store, empty, just frickin empty, you could hear the wind blowin' through
So I was like, "okay"
I went to Ralph's,
same situation
Just a bunch of people...
Full carts, all the way around the store
No chicken!
There was meatloaf
There was a lot of meatloaf
It's like, "guys we have all this meatloaf over here!"
It's like, "No! I'd rather starve to death than eat the meatloaf!"
The toilet paper was the first thing to go
It's like, there are many ways to wipe your butt
If you're quarantined at home, you just take a shower after you take a... dump
(Laughter)
I think there's a line between panic and precaution
we hear a lot in the news, we hear a lot, you know, over social media, but
I think it would be cool to just go around town and actually get a lay of the land here in like, downtown LA
one of the most densely populated places in the country
to see what it's really like out there
You may be wondering why we're in the office right now if we're talking about all these precautions we need to take,
but we're at the point still where we can at least get together, make a plan for things
It's very realistic that as of Wednesday everybody's going to be working from home
so we can be doing our part to prevent a spread of this disease
[Chill music]
There's a cap on the number of people that can be in a building at one time now at these grocery stores
so that means there's a line to get into the grocery store
It looks like they have supplies though. There's people coming out with fully stocked carts
The supplies are here, they just got wiped out of the stores immediately because of panic
so this is a precautionary, uh... measure against panic
So we're going to go head to downtown now to see what some of the stores are like in the city
We're really close to what's called 'Skid Row' here in LA
We have food, there's a supply line - this is a perfect example of it
You know, LA is a distribution hub for a lot of America, a lot of stuff comes in through Long Beach
and it gets shipped out everywhere
So you can see that there's stuff, there's stuff everywhere
It's just a matter of getting it into the trucks and getting it into the right store and getting it into
the hands of people in a safe manner
The only reason that we don't have a supply is because of all the demand
Everybody's getting, the big... big corporations, and small businesses like us,
we're not able to get any... any product
No... no eggs, no beans, no rice because of all the big corporations taking advantage of it
so, small business like us, we don't even have toilet paper when we were one of the first suppliers
that we... that we had. I mean we were buying truckloads of tiolet paper but unfortunatley we cannot find any
Wow
I mean, it's all about self control, you know what I mean?
I mean, there's product out there, there's product, it's just that we humans... made this chaos
And even the prices are going up, they're going crazy
Yeah
I mean uh, toilet paper, we used to sell that for like 12 dollars
Uh, we bought a pallet last week for 20 dollars
We bought it for 20 dollars, when we were buying it for like nine, eight dollars
It's either we get it or someone else gets it, so
More than anything I think its more of self control, you know?
Cause there, there is product out there, it's just that we are the ones making it more harder to get
Okay so this is the market district, it's right next to where we live and work
We were just talking about how, you know, other places are closing down
You had to stand in a line to get into Smart & Final, McDonald's, you can't go in the lobby,
and then here's a bunch of stalls set up on the sidewalk
It's packed, there's people walking around, it's not exactly the most sanitary conditions
So people aren't necessarily taking it the same level of seriousness yet
There's the other concern, which is important to talk about, which is the economic concern
You know, it's like, you take a week off of work, that's a week you're behind on your paycheck
it's a week that you're behind on your bills
It's not an easy thing, I mean, it's something we have to consider at Corridor, like,
I want people to be safe but we also need to make sure that work is getting done,
Especially if we're going to be in a bit of an economic downturn, we need to make sure we have our cashflow
coming in so that everybody still has a job
If you're out of a job right now, apply for unemployment immediately, it takes a little while to go through
You get your job back in a few weeks? Great! No worries! Unemployment doesn't matter
But if you're gonna be out of work for a month or two, get that unemployment right now
to make your ends meet until... this all passes and you can get back into it
You can get unemployment if you're on a 1099, you can get unemployment for temporary leaves also
This is the fashion district, this is basically where a lot of uh...
fabric comes through the United States, once again, coming in from overseas
and, once again, it's a lot quieter than it used to be
Don't be fooled by all the dazzling colors, there's a fifth to a tenth of all the people that are usually here
The CDC has downgraded the virus from 'airborne' to just 'droplet'
which means you actually have to come into contact with fluid, uh, to catch the virus
Now, the important caveat there is that that fluid can be airborne in and of itself whenever you sneeze or cough
That's the whole, like, the three foot radius bubble aspect of it
So if we're just out and about it's not like you could breath in the virus,
but if someone coughs on you, you can absolutely get it
It's about a 20 minute wait to get in
So far yeah
About a 20 minute wait right now
This is the world we've come to
Grocery stores are the new nightclubs, you wait to get in, the bouncer only let's you in when they're at a capacity
and a new person leaves
So you're saying that all the attractive women can go into the grocery store right away
Right
Starbucks is taking away all their chairs so that you get you order to-go and not hang out
Good call
Oh, they've really restocked
I kinda wanna buy things from here
No, right?
It's like... all these veggies, all these fruit
Yeah they're looking pretty stocked, huh?
Yeah, they must have just restocked like, last night
If there's something you need, you should absolutely get it if you get the chance, but like,
don't get, like a month's supply, just get a week's supply
Cause I guarantee you, in a few hours this place is gonna be super crowded with the line
This is not gonna last
I guess we have enough tortilla chips
How you doing man?
Sorry Niko, we're closed
Ohh shoot
Yeah, we're closing up shop
Orders of the mayor
You guy's getting paid at all?
Yeah, company's paying
Really? Oh, good for them
How are you feeling, are you worried at all?
No, no
They just want less people out in the... about
Mmm, on the street
I drove down here at like 8:30,
no traffic
And usually I'm, you know, bumper to bumper at that time on a Monday
Good luck man
Alright, take care guys
Yeah good luck man. Stay safe
I don't really care about it
No
My immune system is good enough, I don't care
Interesting, okay
aaand they're gone
No! My dumplings!
This is the best poki place in all of LA
Right here in the heart of a Japanese grocery store
The best sushi burritos, poki wraps... I'm gonna get some right now
You know, what's kind of spooky is going on Amazon and trying to get baby formula
and that was all sold out, and that was where it was like, "euuh"
that's when I started kinda getting a little worried
I feel like if I just like, chill on buying groceries until like, the end of this week
things will be restocked
I mean, this is a perfect example of what I was talking about, it's like, that is something you need
and you're not gonna hoard a bunch of it, you're just gonna get what you need
The line is crazy right now
There is definitely a storm brewing
Literally and figuratively
Think I'm feeling raindrops
So yeah, that's what it looks like out in LA right now
it's... it's an interesting time, it's important to be taking this seriously
It's important not to panic, go crazy, hoard everything... remember, don't strain the system
The system will work, food will continue to be distributed
We've distributed food through world wars before!
This is okay, we'll be fine
If you wanna start stocking up on things, do it gradually, do it slowly
Don't go to the store and just clean 'em out
I wanna give you guys a handy tip here:
You may notice that stores are sold out of hand sanitizer, sanitizing wipes, sanitizing spray,
all that kind of stuff, all these modern conveniences
But you know what?
It's very, very easy to make your own cleaning liquid
All you need to do is put a little bit of bleach into a big thing of water, basically you'll dilute it
One part bleach to about 20 parts water
You can put that in a spray bottle, you can put it in like, a big tub and you can dip rags in it and wipe things with it
That little bit of bleach and water will disinfect surfaces, it'll disinfect your phone screens,
it's a great way to create your own disinfecting solution
and bleach is very easy to come by. It is not sold out
One of the things we talked about in this video is the economic impact of stores closing down,
restaurants shutting their doors, people having to go on unemployment, things like that
We also wanna make sure that we have the money to pay our bills and keep everybody employed
especially if we're all going to be working from home for a couple weeks here
So, I wanna thank Squarespace for sponsoring this video
Unfortunately, Jake is still in Texas, he'll be back tomorrow
so I'm doing the Squarespace ad for you today!
Whaaat?
But, you know what? Jake has done a great job informing me on the fact that
they have some award-winning templates, it's a very easy to use website, and has lots of great features
that make website building easy and accessible
(Laughs)
Tell me more about Squarespace, Niko
So, Squarespace allows you to purchase your own domains, it has web hosting
and basically makes the whole website building process easy and approachable
and it has a bunch of extra features to let you to take your website beyond just a regular website
For example, you have Audio Blocks
You can get some nice stock audio to put into your podcast,
you have email campaigns that you can run,
you have multi-user contributions so you can have multiple people working on the same site
There's a whole bunch of things that Squarespace does to make website building easy
and we've actually used Squarespace for our site building many times
The templates look awesome, and honestly, all website building aside
Squarespace has actually been a huge beneficial force in the world of online media
They've sponsored a lot of artists to make really cool things, and they really have never been too intrusive,
so, they've done a great job of supporting the arts, so to speak
And with that, I want to thank them!
And if you guys want to check out Squarespace, you can head to squarespace.com/corridorcrew
and you actually get 10% off of a website domain purchase!
So you can buy your own, "blankity-blank.com"!
squarespace.com/corridorcrew, theres information in the description if you would like to click on that
and start building your own website right now
Thank you for watching, everybody
Please stay safe out there, stay level-headed, mature, respectful, cautious
Together, we can get through this without having a pandemic that causes a lot of issues
for our health system, as well as our senior citizens
It's not about whether or not you get sick, it's whether or not the people who are vulnerable get sick
and we all wanna do our part, and keep everyone safe
One more thing: everybody in the office is gonna suggest one good movie for you to watch while you're at home
Easy! Knives Out
My favorite movie of 2019, I just saw it for a second time over the weekend, it is so incredible
it's so intelligently written and directed and perfor- Everything about Knives Out is... is amazing
Lighthouse. It's amazing
Your best bet... is to go through the entire Friday the 13th series
That's 12 movies I just gave you, and... at least three of them are good.
At least three
My girlfriend and I have been going through the entire series of Mad Men
Probably get you through the entire two week quarantine
Next couple months if it gets worse
Just hit up that Disney+ vault
Animated Clone Wars series, I just finished all of Mighty Ducks, I'm watchin' Recess, I'm watchin' Doug
All that stuff is great
Check out this show called Kingdom, it's on Netflix
Really intense zombie series about feudal Korea
Season two just dropped
Shaolin Soccer
Shaolin Soccer?
Go watch Shaolin Soccer, yeah!
I dunno